[Musique]
ce sont des vitrines des vitrines des
futurs vitrine c'est là que les
décorateurs les entrepreneurs et même
les futurs clients viennent admirer
choisir soit sur catalogue soit sur
pièce les décorations qui l'ont installé
chez eux dans les boulangeries dans les
vitres dans les charcuteries dans les
restaurants dans les bars et c'est là
que se trouvent tous les dépôts des
grandes manufactures choisy-le-roi
digoin sarreguemines
c'est la vitrine de la céramique
française
[Musique]
on imagine qu'il devait y avoir à peu
près cinq mille 5000 boutiques ainsi
décoré et il en reste encore 700 en
france ou à paris que je sache
mais le nombre des commandes êtres
fabuleux fabuleux surtout en cette fin
du 19e
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les causes sont multiples c'est d'abord
un problème de consommation il faut
attirer le client
c'est la preuve cette élémentaire mais
l'attiré et les séduire
qu'il y ait un certain rapport entre le
cadre est l'objet que l'on cherche avant
il est bien évident que un décor
bucolique rendra plus sympathique
la pâtisserie ou le bon pain doré que le
boulanger dans l'ordre
[Musique]
elle était basique hier dans la rue du
croissante ces gentilles manière attire
les façons on aimait à l'extrême ses
yeux depuis d'amour sa peau douce comme
la crème et sa bouche un petit four et
du soir au matin dans son petit magasin
elle vendait des petits gâteaux qu'elle
plie est bien comme il faut dans un joli
papier blanc entouré d'un petit ruban
toi elle servait tous les clients en se
trémoussant gentiment à les voir comme
elle sautait retrait de petites brises
soleil
[Musique]
c'est une problème de promotion de
promotion sociale pour le commerçant
mais une manière aussi de flatter le
client le client retrouve dans la
boutique
un décor qui l'a vu dans des châteaux
dans des expositions et ils se sentent
très honoré d'être le client d'une part
une boutique un jour dans la boutique un
vieux monsieur empreint d'un petit coup
d'oeil au blick vite il a remarqué
pourparlers ravel
il choisit des bonbons donnez moi
mademoiselle racornie d'un marron et
d'un air très malins qu'ils ont mis
dedans sa main elle vendait des petits
gâteaux qu'elle plie et bien comme il
faut dans un joli papier blanc en
tournée d'un petit rue portant voulez
vous mon petit paumé marron et mon coeur
chaud car show dit elle roule à vie mais
vous marot sont menacés
[Applaudissements]
c'est un problème aussi d'hygiène nous
sommes en plein d'époque de pasteur
l'hygiène est à la mode
et s'il n'y a pas de s'il n'y a pas d'
instruction du préfet de police encore
il est recommandé que les boutiques
soient propres et rien n'est plus facile
à entretenir qu'une boutique en
céramique crès d'ailleurs internement
jeunes
attendez
madame ne puissons
je suis très heureux de vous rencontrer
parce que j'ai aussi à collectionneur de
cartons de ses cartons qui ont servi à
exécuter les panneaux dont vous avez
quelques types dans votre boutique
ah bon oui je suis moi-même dans la
céramique mais à l'occasion de
déménagement dans une société qui
m'emploie j'ai récupéré un certain
nombre de panneaux et je peux en dire
que j'ai quelques cartons de votre
boutique en validant sa date et sa date
pas d'hier je ne sais pas les gâter avec
exactitude mais vous voyez je fais selon
des recherches dans certains magasins
entre autres dans les frises voici une
collection de chemises
je n'ai pas encore retrouvé la frise que
je trouve très intéressant de la côte
saint jacques aller là-haut et ses jolis
desserts aujourd'hui nous aurions pu
faire ces choses-là on céramique à
l'heure actuelle non non c'était
entièrement pas à la main
mais à une facture est le plus souvent
c'était faire d'un exemplaire unique
ah bon alors je pense par contre que
celle ci est intéressante parce qu'elle
a été faite également dans une autre
poisson née en 1910 et nous la
retrouvons dans un autre magasin 10
noeuds
ou bien alors ça vous ennuie peut-être
que dans d'autres magasins qui est le
leur
[Musique]
je vous réserve une petite surprise
voici par exemple presque grandeur
nature la toile d'exécution d'un label
furieux et ici je les retrouvais n'ont
pas oublié de carton mais perdu au
milieu de vieux bouquins a fait aussitôt
fait le rapprochement
assez curieux des dents je vous félicite
quand même d'avoir su garder ses
panneaux d'époque
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça disparaît tous
les jours parce que voilà les carreaux
qui ont leurs 70 ans bientôt à la fois
hier j'ai beaucoup d'étrangers qui
viennent même qu'on visite et ça
m'étonnerait pas
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup le quartier j'aime
beaucoup mon magasin parce qu'il a un
style ancien et puis j'aime tout ce qui
est ancien et alors il ya les quatre
saisons liée au plafond là c'est pas mal
ça va mais je ne passe pas un jour par
exemple le sentent pas admirer la saison
qui est en face de moi c'est à dire
l'hiver se lire tous les détails
l'hiver elle et de l'est alors les
meilleurs c'est compréhensible si non
mais c'est vrai c'est très joli avec sa
petite église dans le fond là était sage
sa très jolie d'abord on fera plus
jamais des choses comme ça
[Musique]
que j'aime beaucoup ce sont les fleurs
voyez-les en face il ya des liserons et
puis des églantines ont regardé la
fraîcheur de ses de ses bouquets et en
plus le lilas les lilas qui est doux
mais même triple je crois alors au
printemps je trouve que c'est magnifique
de les admirer non c'est vrai à part les
marguerites je leur trouve quelque chose
qu'ils sont moins naturel que les autres
les roses aussi regarder son aile et les
oiseaux ça s'appelait pas beaucoup avant
mariton ce nom un nom du rock cha
voulons non ça très beau
[Musique]
j'avais déjà prouvé elles vendent des
plafonds et je n'ai pas vendu
sp c'est dommage de faire une chose
comme ça vous est proposée combien pour
ce plafond haut on ne savait proposé 10
millions c'est le mal et qu'il voulait
le toute la rangée de papillons qui
étaient autour
alors j'ai dit si je vends mon plafond
et que
ne te plaît de refaire la boutique neuf
et ça nous coûtera plus cher plus que ça
ne coûtera aussi cher
ça m'aurait fait mal au coeur de casser
ça
oui
non si je partais à la campagne je crois
que je le mettrais chez moi maison à
fond je ne vendrai pas beau ce pas une
question d'argent c'est une question que
j'aime les belles choses voilà
[Musique]
et que le rossignol viendra chanter mon
corps
quand le faut
en soufflant sur la mère de vos
meilleurs
nous irons
la chanson des blés d'or
nous irons j'ai écouté la chanson des
blés
non
[Musique]
à petit parfois sous la ramure à l'heure
où chantent les épis et taylor
rejoignent murmure aux monts et vallons
a fini
connais-tu cet endroit profond
qui revient tous les mâles juge
chanter parmi la moisson
des refrains papilles
[Musique]
le décor c'est pas tout faut regarder la
fournit le laboratoire parce que tous
fabricants ben là aussi là c'est la
vente
alors comment ça se passe ici
ici on va la journée commence à 4h30 le
matin jusqu'au soir jusqu'au soir oh oui
sans interruption voyez des moments de
coupure enfin peu ce qu'on veut quand on
est chez soi
évidemment tu travailles quoi bon choix
c'est agréable
une chose qui est intéressante c'est
qu'on est libre on a la liberté
remarquer qu'on la paie chère liberté
vous le dis tout de suite
bon enfin travailler comme ça c'est
agréable on est enfin messieurs deux
jours avec ma femme
la peau de métro à prendre on a
intempéries évidemment il y apporte
tellement d aussi et c'est une question
d'habitude
je vais aider mon mari en bord et puis
je mon fils le mais toujours sur sa
petite chaise et quand je les vois tous
les deux jours je dirais que je prenne
une photo
et puis le 4 qui nous fait pas mal de
tableau que j'aime bien du reste du mot
je lui dis c'est monsieur mon j'aimerais
bien qu'on me métier mon mari et mon
fils un tableau pour mon fils plus tard
il dira tiens comme le je travaillais
comme ça avec mon père ils le sont
oubliées elles sont bonnes et ta sourire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réalisé pour le compte du
secrétariat d'état à la culture
un inventeur de l'ensemble des
boutique ancien qui existent encore
barré ce sont des éléments souvent d'une
qualité remarquable parce qu'il ya eu de
véritables créations dans ce domaine et
je trouve qu'il participe pleinement à
leur rôle de témoin de l'architecturé
commerciale passé dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui ces fonds de commerce ont
pour la plupart encore en exploitation
c'est un véritable musée vivant en plein
air que l'on rencontre à chaque coin de
rue et qui présente des éléments de
décoration aussi bien à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur
[Musique]
mais c'était mme lottin il représente le
labour d'abord et puis après à ce my et
puis ensuite évidemment il faut tout
pour le faire le pain il ya le faut et
les glaneuses sur les autres tableaux
qui un lundi quasiment des reproductions
de peintres du 19e siècle oui je sais
très bien ça me savais malade de quand
votre bien est là les immeubles ils ont
102 ans je crois que la boulangerie a
été fait dans ces moments-là 1912 à
paris quelque chose comme ça et les
mosaïques en jamais été changé sa
lagarde comme nous le dit ça fait
combien de temps que vous occupez ça
fait 26 ans qu'est ce qui va se passer
quand l'équipe est à ça je ne sais pas
si mes enfants veulent bien continuer
puisqu'ils sont dans le métier je
m'étais mars en lançant dans le métier
veulent bien là continuer ça ira et je
pense qu'ils font pas de changement mais
si je la vends quelqu'un d'autre ça
pourrait une fois changé
[Musique]
bon
à
on
[Musique]
enfin madame rêve éclair au chocolat
s'il vous plaît du clan chocolat voilà
voilà on avait la certitude par exemple
une autre boulangerie succès de votre
fonds de commerce il n'y aura aucun
problème ici mais ce qui se passe très
souvent dans paris c'est que quand tu as
commerçants s'en va généralement son
fond de commerce est transformé on y
trouve une banque un cabinet
d'assurances et à ce moment là on a
énormément de risque de voir disparaître
l'ensemble des codes ça me fait déjà
dans la boulange et il ya beaucoup de
boulangers qui ferment gens mangent
moins en moins de pas et bien sûr il se
peut que la personne qui viennent
derrière même si d'ailleurs c'est à
boulanger qui puisse ne pas apprécier le
style de la boutique au cices c'est pour
ça que c'est nous aimerions trouver un
mode de protection adaptées adapté au
commerce mais je pense que c'est très
difficile de posséder les deux
classements
c'est gênant parce qu'on peut pas
déplacer les meubles on peut pas
dépasser vitrine qu'est ce que vous
aimez votre ami beaucoup alors si elles
risquent d'être détruites qu'est ce que
vous seriez prête à fait ce moment que
je ne le vois pas je préfère cibles à
détruire que je la vois pas ça quand je
serai plus vieille quand je serais parti
[Musique]
oui
quand on est chez vous roxane on a un
peu l'impression d'être dans la rue
puisqu'il ya la rue qui a constitué ici
ça correspond à mon amour de la rue
parisienne que j'ai essayé de
reconstituer dans mon appartement aussi
bien avec des enseignes qu avec du
mobilier urbain pour la mesure de mes
possibilités
alors vous retrouver au cinquième étage
que vous avez l'habitude de retrouver
sur le trottoir
ce pas nous décor est l'arrière salle de
café situé 100 e rue de turenne un café
qui s'appelait à l'aviation parce que ça
représente l'aviation comme vous pouvez
voir sous les traits de cette dame en
robe jaune
l'aviation est en train de kidnapper le
jeune marié qui la regardent d'un air
énamouré et qui s'envole dans une
véritable caisse à savon poursuivi par
la belle mère pendant que son épouse et
pleure sur les épaules de son père sur
la butte montmartre
vous voyez le moulin et l'artiste a
représenté une vue très naïve de paris
avec la tour eiffel est l'ancien
trocadéro et quel rôle du collectionneur
fou ben si surtout celui de sauver parce
qu'un collectionneur n'a qu'une vie
humaine et la plupart des grandes
collections finissent toujours dans les
grands fonds publics
alors je pense que peut-être un jour ma
collection danse émirats au musée
carnavalet parce que je le souhaite
beaucoup le musée par aux définitions
ccc bête ça conserve sa fonction est de
conserver et s'il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions pour sauver ces documents il
faut les mettre au musée mais le musée
ce serait celle-là décès la solution de
désespoir
est ce qu'on pensait pas que le
collectionneur risque d'encourager la
transformation peut-être la destruction
de certaines enseignes qui sont dans la
rue
d'habitude à ne croyait pas ça parce que
toutes les enseignes que j'ai acheté je
les ai vus à la suite de rénovation ou
de départ à la retraite ou de
modernisation
quand les gens modernise quand par
exemple les vieux commerçant revendait
les gens plus jeunes et qui veulent
mettre du néon quand les boutiques sont
un peu transformés quand ils
s'aperçoivent que les vieilles enseignes
on ne livre pas la nuit parce qu'elles
sont jamais éclairé alors ce moment je
les récupère
[Musique]
ici vous avez la boulangerie des statuts
les si beaux panneaux sur fond noir
vous voyez la petite glaneuse cher à
doisneau il l'a photographiée en gros
dans son dernier livre sur le décor de
paris ce sont toujours des professions
de des travaux des champs il ya un
faucheur un autre faucheur des glaneuses
souvent avec les moulins à vent et les
moulins à eau ce sont en général les
décors de boulangerie qu'on retrouve le
plus il y à issy ainsi faucheurs tout à
fait charmant qu'un de mes amis prétend
être peints par renoir et évidemment il
n'est pas de renoir mais certains grands
peintres ont fait des décors de
boulangerie et des décors de boutiques
beaucoup plus qu'on ne croit au début de
leur carrière leurs droits elles étaient
94 rue de la tombe issoire à l'angle de
la rue du père corentin dans le 14e
maintenant il ya une très belle
boulangerie moderne qui s'appelle la
boulangerie du moulin de la marjolaine
j'aurais préféré qu'elle reste en place
parce que je trouve que c'est dans la
rue qu'elle ne doive être et il y en a
encore beaucoup dans paris vous savez
énormément il certains boulangers savent
ce qu'ils ont ils cherchent à les
protéger
il vaut toujours mieux que quelque chose
soit en place plutôt que dans un musée
et tant qu'à les voir démolir
j'essaye de les récupérer pour les
sauver
[Musique]
c'est à nous en tant qu'installateur
décorateur de faire bénéficier pliant de
l'expérience et de lui demander de
demander aux clients ce qu'ils désirent
faire dans son dans sa boutique le souci
du client ici notamment était d'agrandir
c'est pourquoi on va battre des cloisons
des choses comme ça ce qui nous a
obligés du reste à démonter le le
plafond qui ne serait plus du tout dans
le cadre de la boutique mais le décor de
l'intérieur sera totalement différent on
ne cherchera pas du tout à copier à
l'intérieur le décor de la façade et
quant aux peintures sous verre là elles
vont être fait parce que soit sa vie
belle oui alors le problème des
peintures sous verre évidemment ça
serait très très bien de pouvoir les
refermer malheureusement alors ce sont
des pièces auxquelles on ne peut pas
toucher parce que ce sont des toiles
patch qui sont ensuite collées sur des
vitres mais boétie dont mais ce sont des
objets si on avait le malheur de les
démonter autres on est à peu près sûr
que on ferait plus de dégâts que deux
de bon travail
[Musique]
évidemment
je regrette un peu le style ancien
m'enfin qui se voulait un moderne
maintenant que c'est surtout ça qui
compte
le plafond évidemment je ne peux pas le
garder si je trouve un acquéreur
j'en prendrais volontiers vous voulez
combien
disons que autour de 2 millions anciens
enfin c'est à discuter
peut-être plus pourquoi par l'extérieur
afin d'annexer classé par les beaux-arts
je suis un peu obligé de laisser dans le
style alors
je ne peux pas faire autrement ce
dommage parce que j'aurais bien voulu
tout changer
enfin tant pis
[Musique]
pourquoi ce bandeau qui a remplacé par
un parent un bloc de plastique
c'est exactement s'ils ont la même chose
que si on prenait la joconde pendant
couper la moitié qu'on la remplace par
un bout de formica je crois que en
quatre ans dans cet aperçu dans paris il
y avait à peu près 300 boutiques qui
avait disparu de ce type qui avait été
dégradée
il reste dans paris encore de 700
boutiques
d'autre part il se refait 15 cents
boutiques tous les ans ça signifie tout
simplement qu'en moins de six mois
toutes les boutiques en scène pourrait
disparaître j'espère tout du moins que
l'inventaire des boutiques ancien que
nous sommes en train de réaliser pour le
compte du secrétariat d'état à la
culture permettra dans une dans un
premier temps au moins de localiser les
éléments les plus importants de tenter
s'il est possible
1 une action de classement type
monuments historiques
mais ce que j'aimerais davantage c'est
une sensibilisation aussi bien des
commerçants des décorateurs des
entrepreneurs et de la population
[Musique]
ce
non
pour tous les faire au monde entier
on
moi
monde entier
[Musique]
oui je suis du quartier pourquoi qu'est
ce que vous voulez savoir s'est
longtemps que ça depuis ma naissance a
fait 73 ans j'ai jamais quitté mon
village
lahrissi paris pour moi le 11e c'est un
grand village dans ce village où sont
beaucoup de camps dont cette galerie
affaire de maison est un canton pour
nous c'est un joli bourg que nous aimons
inquiets et malheureusement été
défigurée par les maisons en ciment
qu'ils ont fabriqué ici derrière moi
vous voyez une boulangerie d'après les
dires des anciens a été construit
environ vers 1890
c'est la plus vieille du quartier et
vous pouvez admirer encore les tableaux
qui a le long de la façade
ils n'ont jamais changé ainsi qu'à
l'intérieur la mosaïque qui a été déposé
mais celle qui est en face à votre côté
alors celle qui est en face de l'autre
côté l'avant el hadath debise le sens
des 218 212 d'un avant la guerre de 14
semaines
elle a toujours été comme ça
l'intérieur ouimet l'extérieur non
l'extérieur était pareil que celui qui a
l'a beaucoup de voitures sont entrées
dans la phase des façades ont été faites
comme elles sont maintenant
ce panneau c'est d'abord une enseigne
mais c'est aussi une manière d'attirer
le client en utilisant le talent de
peintre populaires qui sont des
professionnels et qui s'inspire des
peintures officielle de l'époque de la
fin du 19ème début xxème siècle et c'est
le cycle la nature parce que le pain est
une nourriture naturelle
alors comment aussi si par un paysage
complètement vierge que l'homme n'a pas
touché socratique maison et puis dans
tous les panneaux peints que le
boulanger demande à voir ce fronton sur
son magasin on va voir l'homme petit à
petit intervenir sur la nature est
d'abord il va intervenir comme choix
laboureur soit chômeur c'est le début du
site du pin et voilà ici on a le summer
du laboureur on le voit sur d'autres
boulangeries
doucement voici le temps qu'a sonné ne
verra le ciel pour procéder aux premiers
rayons du soleil le sillon béant dans la
ville attend le moment où ta main
[Musique]
que dans les si l'on ne la perd se
répondent
[Musique]
à
demain
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses dernières va tomber tout le cycle de
la meunerie les moulins à eau avant
derrière
bien entendu tout à boulange c'est à
dire le pétrissage du pain la cuisson et
puis l'ultime maillon de la chaîne
la vente du pain soit la vente du pain
dans le magasin lui-même choisi qui
était d'une profession qui a disparu la
veille de la guerre de 14
le pain portés à domicile et à la petite
porteuse de pain autour duquel s'est
construit tout un légendaire c'est une
fille du peuple méritante orpheline elle
est en quelque sorte l'aboutissement ou
la représentation presque virginale de
cette nourriture extrêmement naturelle
qui est partie au départ de la nature
plus brute est toute simple avec l'eau
vive marièrent plan c'était la patronne
calédonien je faisais
et comme vous le savez ça par une
cliente qui est c'était son mari qu'il
faisait la peinture c'est tout malik
était signée que ses concurrents d'être
ici vous avez le fondre qu'il le fait
j'ai rien fait les beaux jeunes c'est
comme ça c'est le peintre italien lapin
et le tableau de l'autre côté c'est le
mitron aussi vous prédécesseur la
lagarde à 14
ces moments va virer 14 18 ses tableaux
la route eiffel à la place de la
république l'a taclé les fiacres de le
concret et qui portait son temps
tiens je n'y pense à une solide et oui
sparkasse d'être un jour il y avait des
jolies comme ça
l appétit
[Musique]
on savait
mon snow jam ah oui l'enflure ans qui
s'appelait
mais qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous
dans la boutique moi je servais mettez
le pin gris et les gâteaux qu'ils ont
mangé
quand ils m'ordonnaient pas d'offre des
pompiers pour vous travaillez beaucoup à
l'époque parce qu'on pose commencé le
matin à 5h45
on avait une heure pour les sens ça
change et l'après midi et le soir
jusqu'à 10 heures le temps de
débarrasser nettoyer les grilles lavez
les plateaux des gâteaux ben ouais je
servais nous avait beaucoup de projets
congé il deux journées par mois
seulement oui et donc votre patronne
elle était très dur non la patronne
oui tout pas du tout au contraire de
monter ce que je voulais montrer à l'eau
des familles à qui tu veux manger il ya
de la randonnée 10 en francs puis
j'allais me chasser des campus où vous
avez gardé un bon souvenir de santé 2 et
que ces deux bâtons très bien ça ça
voyez je voudrais bien hier commencer
même que je travaillais dur
faire cuire tournerait voyez dure école
de ce que tu as sommer dit la morale
elle cette époque là est le sauveur
récolte bien entendu son blé et puis le
blé va rentrer de vinci d'exorciser ou à
chacun storia référence à la morale
curieusement la morale du travail
d'abord qui est une morale on essaye de
faire accepter à l'homme du 19e siècle
aux travailleurs du 19e siècle qui ne
s'est pratiquement pas lire
on est obligé donc de coder sa part des
signes ils sont des skieuses des images
essentiellement il se trouve que les
gens du peuple ne vont pas dans les
musées et c'est le musée qui descendent
dans la rue si on peut dire par là bien
des pâtres populaire qui inspire de
grandes oeuvres moral des peintres 19e
miley en occurrence que le premier le
plus important donne à voir cette morale
en action l'immensité des cieux les
mollahs pleurs
la cendre du jour
retire mais pense à charge
les sapins heures
redon la montagne
sont faut dire à travers
[Musique]
devant leur me supplie
à l'horizon
le sort et les sens
ma fais moi c'est les voeux de la vie
m
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais en droit
ma
la paix
la vie
mais mon idée
m
ep
je vais pouvoir allemand
bondé
moi en thaïlande
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
dans ce monde du deuxième siècle où un
certain nombre de révoltes ouvrières
sont latentes dont déjà éclaté qu'il
s'agisse de la commune s'agit de la
révolte des canuts lyonnais
il faut ré enfermé l'ouvrît en quelque
sorte dans un ordre moral
ils doivent accepter c'est un bon moral
il est symbolisé par ses peintures sur
verre
les boulangers s'en font les complices
involontaires et devons faire descendre
dans la rue
la morale bourgeoise et la donner à lire
par le biais des images
[Musique]
nous avions une fraternité qui n'existe
plus maintenant dans aucun quartier de
paris jamais aucun d'eux ne mourrait de
faim car nous entendions pour partager
notre pas notre argent comme nous disait
si bien et c'était du pain c'était pas
comme maintenant
l'un c'était vrai il était blanc bon les
enfants pouvaient se permettre à 4h de
manger une bonne tartine de pain soit
vrai quand il y avait du corps dans les
familles où soitec tue souvent c'est que
gorée m'enfin c'est le quartier qui
voulait ça
de toute façon le pain les plus
l'aliment de première nécessité comme
auparavant non des boulangeries comme
ici il ya seulement ratant faisait le
double le double de quintaux c'est sympa
aussi au changement de la population de
paris aussi un peu ça ici surtout ici
c'est un quartier en rénovation
alors beaucoup de gens s'en vont mais
quand même les jeunes mangent beaucoup
moins de pain ma pensée c'est périmé st
il a transformé à la wii c'était un
véritable village ouvrier avait que des
ouvriers des petites années d'artisans
horvàth et puis maintenant là vous voyez
ce fouillis qui avoue le fouillis qu'on
nous offre que nous apprendre qu est ce
qui vient la tête de lui-même dans un
terrain vague avec les arts fruitiers
bras elle était bonne justice c'était
comme s'il avait été là dès fortis et
jacques fruitiers nous les enfants nous
avions droit de venir déguster les
fruits au moment de j'étais mûr quoi des
cerises des poires des preuves y avait
tout là-dedans dépêche
et tout ça gratuitement
c'était nous les mondes du quartier on
rabat est là
c'est vrai
et l agent en quoi un oui on avait 20
ans alors même qu'on l'avait 10 nous en
voudraient bien lire principe
ouais ouais
pourrait-il moulin place blanche on t'a
valu mon bistrot du coin les jours comme
c'était dimanche ressentir les amis les
copains ressent-il tous mes vieux bal
musette leur java ou son de l'accordéon
on chante ils tous mes pinceaux galette
avec un freeze hadrons
ou s'en tire donc
mais montmartre semble disparaître
car déjà de saison en saison
des abbesses à la place du tertre ont
démoli nos vieilles maisons
sur les terrains vagues de la butte de
grandes banques mettront bientôt vous
ferez vous à landreau qui luttent vous
des preuves un ca plus haut en
regrettant le temps jadis
nous chanterons pensante salissent
montmatre ton des profondeurs où est-il
mon moulin la flèche blanche
bon ça vas y mon bistrot du coin
tous les jours pour nous c'était
dimanche
sentir nos amis dont copains on s'en
tire tout ne va le musée
laure java au son de l'accordéon
où sont ils pour mettre fins aux lettres
avec un cornet de frites à devant
où sont ils
[Musique]
vous sentir tous mes vieux bal musette
java trop sont à craindre
nous sommes tous mes records sont garés
quand je bouffais même sans abri
où sont ils
vos dons
[Musique]